le festival des couleurs est une
célébration de l'arrivée du printemps et
du triomphe du bien sur le mal
c'est la fête la plus joyeuse en inde
célébrée depuis le quatrième siècle
cette année c'est aussi une incroyable
machine à remonter le temps qui nous
transporte à l'époque où la pandémie de
comics 19 n'existait pas cette jeune
femme a fait cinq heures de route pour
venir fêter havre endavant dans le nord
de l'inde
9 mai prochain le festival la remplit de
bonheur et lui permet de rencontrer
clède étrangers dans les bus bondés
personne n'échappe aux gentils aux
attaques de poudre et d'eau colorée pas
le droit d'être fâché la journée de
holly peu à peu la musique résonne
l'esprit de la fête prend le dessus
[Musique]
ça fait du bien résume ce fêtard ses
amis se sert dans leurs bras la
distanciation sociale n'existe plus ici
si vous êtes chanceux nous croiser
quelques rares personnes qui portent un
masque pote tu n as pas volé d'ailleurs
les festivals où il y est aussi une fête
spirituelle
les fidèles viennent au temple rendre
hommage au dieu krishna play off
et pourquoi pas prier qu'il mette un
terme à la pandémie
pour fêter il faut passer chez le
marchand de poudre colorée chaque
couleur a sa propre signification orange
pour l'optimisme jaune pour la joie vert
pour le renouveau et bleu pour la
vitalité
une fois le choix fait c'est le temps
d'attaquer gentiment les passes
aujourd'hui c'est la joie la fête
l'insouciance et demain le brutal retour
à la réalité à la progression
inquiétante de la corée 19 en inde et au
spectre de nouveau confinement
et si philippe leblanc très coloré
aujourd'hui radio canada traîne d'avant
on aide